Kate Aurthur became the rat columnist for New York magazine because she believed, in some way, that rats were at the heart of life in the Big City. Every New Yorker, she says, has a story about a rat. The singer and actor, Ru Paul, found an alley near City Hall with, he said, a thousand rats in it. If he'd fallen off his bicycle, he swore they'd a killed him.
凯特·奥瑟之所以成为《纽约》杂志的老鼠专栏作家，是因为她相信，从某种程度上说，老鼠是这座大城市生活的核心。她说，每个纽约客都有一个关于老鼠的故事。歌手兼演员鲁保罗说，他在市政厅附近发现了一条小巷，里面有一千只老鼠。他发誓说，如果他从自行车上摔下来，它们肯定会咬死他。
I think he was exaggerating. But I did go to that alley at night and it was, by far, the most rats I've ever seen in one place.
我想他夸大其词了。但我确实在晚上去过那条小巷，那绝对是我见过老鼠聚集最多的地方。
I'm picturing like a carpet of rats.
我脑海中浮现出像地毯一样的老鼠。
I was with a friend of mine who was driving, and we stopped at the end of the alley and turned out her lights. There's so much garbage, first of all, so they were just climbing all over the place. So it was very disturbing, because they were actually at our eye level. And I mean, it was terrifying. We're in a big truck and it didn't seem safe enough, like to be in an Isuzu Trooper. It seemed like they had the advantage. I mean, she was screaming so loudly that I became afraid of her. It was terrible. I was like drive, drive! It was terrible.
当时我和一个开车的朋友在一起，我们在小巷尽头停下车，关掉了车灯。首先，那里的垃圾太多了，所以它们到处乱爬。这非常令人不安，因为它们的高度正好和我们的视线平行。我是说，那太可怕了。我们坐在一辆大卡车里，比如五十铃旅行者，但感觉还是不够安全。似乎它们占据了上风。我是说，她尖叫得那么大声，连我都开始害怕她了。太糟糕了。我当时只想说：快开车！快开车！真是太可怕了。
Well from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories of nature creeping into the most man-made environments possible. Nature sneaking in places where it's very existence is a rebuke to the notion that we, as a species, have it under control. When vermin infiltrate your house, or my house, there's this feeling of it's us versus them. It's a contest with nature where it suddenly feels like nature might actually win.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目讲述大自然潜入最人造环境的故事。大自然潜入那些它本身的存在就是对“我们作为一个物种已经控制了一切”这一观念的有力反驳的地方。当害虫潜入你的房子，或者我的房子时，就会产生一种“我们与它们对抗”的感觉。这是一场与大自然的较量，有时你会突然觉得大自然可能真的会赢。
I'm from Brooklyn. I mean, I'm from the streets of Brooklyn. I was born, raised, and probably will die.
我是布鲁克林人。我是说，我是在布鲁克林的街头长大的。我出生在这里，在这里长大，可能也会死在这里。
This is from this great documentary by Mark Lewis called-- simply enough-- Rats.
这段话出自马克·刘易斯的一部精彩纪录片，片名很简单，就叫《老鼠》。
And I mean, I know what a mentality is, a street mentality is. I know when somebody takes on that type of a role. And I when I looked into the eyes of the rats, I mean, I could see that they had an intelligence just like in the street where it's not just one kid, you're facing up to 20 kids. They all have the single-minded presence of mind to do what they have to do to you.
我是说，我知道什么是街头心态。我知道当某人扮演那种角色时是什么样。当我看向那些老鼠的眼睛时，我能看出它们有着和街头一样的智慧，不仅仅是一两个小混混，你面对的是20个孩子。它们都有着极其专注的意志，去做它们必须对你做的事。
Usually, when we talk about man versus nature, and we build these urban environments and we quash nature and we control nature, there's a part of us that believes that we should be rooting for nature. That nature means beautiful greenery and the clear blue sky and the deep blue sea. But when weeds breakthrough our perfectly paved sidewalk, when the cockroaches march in, when the rat arrives, we remember why we wanted to tame nature in the first place.
通常，当我们谈论人与自然的对抗，当我们建造这些城市环境并压制大自然、控制大自然时，我们内心深处总有一部分相信我们应该站在大自然这一边。大自然意味着美丽的绿地、清澈的蓝天和深蓝的大海。但是，当杂草冲破我们完美铺就的人行道，当蟑螂大举入侵，当老鼠出现时，我们就会记起当初为什么想要驯服大自然。
Rats showed up at this guy's house, and he tried ceiling walls and he tried poisoning them, he tried chasing them and killing them with a two by four, and still they came, and multiplied. Terrorizing his family, finally forcing them to move.
老鼠出现在这个人的家里，他尝试封堵墙壁，尝试毒死它们，尝试追赶它们并用木板打死它们，但它们还是不断涌现，不断繁殖。它们恐吓他的家人，最终迫使他们搬家。
I really do believe that they knew that they won. Because remember, when you do look inside of his eyes, you can see he's got a soul. He's got something inside of him, and he's looking right back at you. He wants you just as bad as you want him. It's you or him. I know when I was there I wished the rats dead. If I could of, I would have killed each one by hand myself personally. It brought my family terror, horror, economic grief. So yeah, I definitely held a grudge against them. They scarred me and they scarred my family, and will always be with us.
我真的相信它们知道自己赢了。因为记住，当你看着它的眼睛时，你能看到它有灵魂。它的内心有某种东西，它正盯着你看。它想要征服你，就像你想要消灭它一样。不是你死就是它活。我知道当时我在那里时，恨不得那些老鼠死绝。如果可以的话，我会亲手把它们一只只掐死。它们给我的家人带来了恐惧、惊骇和经济损失。所以，是的，我确实对它们怀恨在心。它们伤害了我，也伤害了我的家人，这种阴影将永远伴随着我们。
Well today on our program, five stories of nature seeping into man-made environments, stripping the veneer of civilization off of us in the process. Act one, Interpretation of Dreams. In which we hear how an entire nation has coped with the sheer trauma of what it means to knock down trees, rip into the earth, and all the other things you have to do to nature when you build a modern, industrial city. Act two, One Brave Man Stands Up For What's Right. In which one of America's best known politicians goes mono a mono on behalf of human beings against the untamed wilderness.
今天我们的节目有五个故事，讲述大自然渗透进人造环境，并在此过程中剥去我们文明的外衣。第一幕：《梦的解析》。我们将听到一个国家是如何应对那种因建造现代工业城市而必须砍伐树木、破坏土地等对自然造成的创伤的。第二幕：《勇敢者挺身而出捍卫正义》。美国一位知名政治人物代表人类对抗未被驯服的荒野。
Act three, Church of Latter Day Snakes. Scott Carrier tells the true story of one family experiment at bringing the outdoors indoors. Act four, God Bless the Hamster Who Has His Own. In which an average high school student explains why it is bad luck for any animal to become her pet. Act five, Waiting For the End of the World. The writer Iggy Scam hits the road to test a theory about the men who fish. Maybe you've seen these guys right in the middle of the Big City. Stay with us.
第三幕：《后期圣徒之蛇教》。斯科特·卡里尔讲述了一个家庭试图将户外环境带入室内的真实故事。第四幕：《上帝保佑拥有宠物的仓鼠》。一位普通高中生解释了为什么任何动物成为她的宠物都是不幸的。第五幕：《等待世界末日》。作家伊吉·斯卡姆踏上旅程，去验证关于钓鱼者的理论。也许你在大城市中间见过这些人。请继续收听。
Act one, Interpretation of Dreams. Building everything that we think of as modern life, cities and suburbs both, means trammeling nature. And that bothers some people, they want to keep nature at hand. Even if they're living in the heart of the city. Even if the part of nature they're trying to preserve is something most of us can't see and never notice. David Rakoff brings us this case example.
第一幕：《梦的解析》。我们所认为的现代生活——城市和郊区——的建设过程，意味着对大自然的践踏。这让一些人感到不安，他们想要留住身边的大自然。即使他们住在城市中心。即使他们试图保留的那部分自然是我们大多数人看不见、从未注意到的东西。大卫·拉科夫为我们带来了这个案例。
Grasteinn, literally gray rock, is a famous boulder in Reykjavik, Iceland. It sits cracked in two, fat and satisfied on its own square of sod. On two occasions in the last 30 years, plans were underway to expand the road and detonate the rock. Both times, locals came forward and protested the destruction, claiming that the rock was inhabited by "hidden people." Invisible beings from another dimension who, along with elves and trolls, are a mainstay of Icelandic folklore.
Grasteinn，字面意思是“灰石”，是冰岛雷克雅未克一块著名的巨石。它裂成两半，胖乎乎地安坐在属于它的一块草地上。在过去的30年里，曾两次有计划要扩建道路并炸掉这块石头。两次都有当地人站出来抗议，声称这块石头里住着“隐身人”。这些来自另一个维度的隐形存在，与精灵和巨魔一样，是冰岛民间传说的支柱。
And both times, despite a complete lack of concrete evidence, indeed despite a complete lack of even a history of tales attached to that rock, the Icelandic Public Roads Administration heeded these protests and spared the boulder.
两次，尽管缺乏具体的证据，甚至连关于那块石头的历史传说都完全没有，冰岛公共道路管理局还是听从了这些抗议，放过了这块巨石。
Prior to my arrival, Victor Ingolfsson, chief of the publishing unit for the Public Roads Administration-- their PR guy-- had sent me an article he had written that explained the decision. It is titled, "The Public Roads Administration and the Belief in Elves." It turns out to be quite beautifully written. In addition to his day job, Victor is a novelist. His third book has been on the national bestseller list for months. But its tone is an interesting mixture of exasperation and respect for the feelings of others.
在我抵达之前，公共道路管理局出版部门负责人、也就是他们的公关人员维克多·英戈尔夫松发给我一篇文章，解释了这个决定。文章标题为《公共道路管理局与对精灵的信仰》。事实证明这篇文章写得非常优美。除了日常工作，维克多还是一位小说家。他的第三本书已经在全国畅销榜上待了几个月。但文章的基调是恼火与对他人的尊重之间的一种有趣的混合。
He writes, "A lot of time goes into answering the same old questions. It is hope that this text will rectify the situation and it can be looked upon as the author's interpretation of the PRA's view on the issue. It will not answer the question of whether the PRA's employees do or do not believe in elves and hidden people because opinion differs greatly, and it tends to be a rather personal matter. However, you may assume that the author severely doubts the existence of such phenomena."
他写道：“很多时间都花在回答那些陈词滥调的问题上。希望这份文稿能纠正这种局面，它可以被看作作者对道路管理局在此问题上的观点的解读。它不会回答道路管理局的员工是否相信精灵和隐身人的问题，因为众说纷纭，这往往是个相当私人的问题。然而，你可以推断作者本人严重怀疑此类现象的存在。”
In person, I ask him about this.
见面时，我问了他这个问题。
This belief in these hidden people is primarily a quaint folk tradition, not really believed by many people.
这种对隐身人的信仰主要是一种古雅的民间传统，并没有多少人真的相信。
Yeah that's right.
是的，没错。
I wonder why you guys make any concessions?
我想知道你们为什么要做出让步？
Of this? Because the people who do believe, they are pretty serious about it.
因为那些相信的人，他们对此相当认真。
But certainly we have people who believe in a lot of things that nobody else believes in, in the larger community, and we would never even think--
但我们社区里肯定也有人相信很多别人不相信的东西，我们绝不会想到——
But this is a small community. So basically, everyone knows everyone, almost. So you really have to listen to everyone because you are probably going to meet them at a party after awhile. You know, when you scream at someone in traffic in New York, you know you're probably not going to meet them again, so you do it. But not so much here I think.
但这是一个小社区。所以基本上，每个人几乎都认识每个人。所以你真的必须听取每个人的意见，因为过一会儿你很可能就会在聚会上见到他们。你知道，在纽约，当你在交通堵塞中对人大喊大叫时，你知道你可能不会再见到他们了，所以你才会那么做。但在我看来，这里并不是这样。
I heard stories as a child, yes. But I don't think that people took it seriously.
我小时候确实听过故事。但我认为人们并不当真。
Arni Bjornsson is a cultural anthropologist and head of the ethnological department of the National Museum. He is a sweet-looking, beetle-browed grandfatherly type. A man in his 70s, who, like Viktor, also seems wistfully regretful that the pretext that gets someone like me onto an airplane and over to Iceland is to scrutinize this daffy, essentially non-representative aspect of their society.
阿尼·比约恩松是一位文化人类学家，也是国家博物馆民族学系主任。他是一位长相温和、浓眉大眼的祖父型人物。他70多岁了，和维克多一样，似乎也为这样一个事实感到惆怅和遗憾：像我这样的人之所以能坐飞机来到冰岛，竟然是为了审视他们社会中这种怪诞且基本不具代表性的方面。
Imagine you were outside of a jazz club, a place devoted to a quintessentially American art form, and a reporter from another country comes up and microphone in hand, starts quizzing you on why so many high-rises here don't have 13th floors.
试想一下，你站在一家爵士乐俱乐部外，那是一个致力于某种典型的美国艺术形式的地方，然后一位外国记者走过来，手持麦克风，开始盘问你为什么这里的许多高楼都没有13层。
Now, but when you were a child, did you believe in them?
那么，当你还是个孩子的时候，你相信它们吗？
I didn't believe in them, but I didn't exclude the possibility. In my own farm there were two cliffs, and there was said that there lived some hidden people in there. And you should not cut the grass near the cliffs, because it belonged to the hidden people. Those were the stories.
我不相信，但我没有排除这种可能性。在我自己的农场里有两处悬崖，据说那里住着隐身人。你不应该在悬崖附近割草，因为那是属于隐身人的。那都是些故事。
This turns out to be a paradigmatic model, which I hear over and over again. The story of the grass belonging to the hidden people that must never be cut.
这成了一个范式模型，我一次又一次地听到。关于草地属于隐身人、绝对不能割草的故事。
The other model of story that keeps coming up is one of benevolent wish fulfillment. Mortal women fall into slumbers from which they cannot be woken. In this dream state, they are visited by hidden people. And having performed some service or having been fallen in love with, these mortal women are given pieces of fine cloth. Much finer than anything available to them in their waking lives.
另一个不断出现的模型是关于善意的愿望实现。凡人妇女陷入昏睡，无法被唤醒。在这种梦境状态下，她们会受到隐身人的探访。在提供了一些服务或坠入爱河后，这些凡人妇女会得到精致的布料。比她们清醒生活中所能接触到的任何东西都要精致得多。
The world of the hidden people is a sort of a dream world. They are like human beings, but if anything, they are more beautiful. They had better houses in the hills and the cliffs. They had better furniture. They had better clothes. They had better food.
隐身人的世界是一种梦境世界。他们就像人类，但如果说有什么不同的话，那就是他们更美丽。他们在山丘和悬崖里有更好的房子，有更好的家具，有更好的衣服，有更好的食物。
Freud's theory of dreams is ultimately that they are at heart, disguised versions of unacceptable wishes, of infantile desires whose fulfillment is necessarily unhealthy or unattainable. In a country as physically inhospitable as Iceland, its cold, seemingly endless winter with only five hours of smudgy daylight. Things as basic as warmth, clothing, sufficient food and companionship, might all be seen as inappropriate eruptions from the id. But it still begs the question, what possible purpose do these stories serve today?
弗洛伊德的梦境理论最终认为，梦本质上是不可接受愿望的伪装形式，是那些其实现必然是不健康或无法达到的婴儿期欲望。在一个像冰岛这样自然条件恶劣的国家，在那漫长而寒冷的冬天，每天只有五小时昏暗的日光，温暖、衣物、充足的食物和陪伴等基本需求，都可能被视为本我中不恰当的爆发。但这仍然引出一个问题：这些故事在今天有什么用呢？
Present day Reykjavik is a completely modern city, essentially immune to the nasty brutishness of nature. Still, the stories that hearken from that hardscrabble time are fondly remembered and closely guarded by nearly everyone I talk to.
现代雷克雅未克是一个完全现代化的城市，基本免疫于大自然那粗暴的残酷。然而，那些源于艰苦岁月的传说，依然被我交谈过的几乎每个人所珍视和守护。
When I was about 10 years old, I saw an elf.
我大概10岁的时候，见过一个精灵。
Where?
在哪里？
In my house.
在我家里。
Let me interrupt here and paint a picture. This is not some sod hat-dwelling yokel I am talking to. This woman works in a trendy clothing store on Laugavegur, Reykjavik's main shopping street. She is wearing a long black skirt, a shiny dark red top, a glittery boa, and black felt platform boots. This is one hip chick.
让我在这里打断一下，描述一下画面。我谈话的对象可不是什么住在草屋里的乡巴佬。这位女士在雷克雅未克主要购物街劳加韦格的一家时尚服装店工作。她穿着一条黑色长裙，一件亮眼的深红色上衣，戴着一条闪闪发光的波亚围巾，脚蹬黑色厚底靴。这绝对是个时髦的女孩。
What did he look like?
他长什么样？
You know, like you see on the drawings of them. Small, a little hat.
你知道，就像你在图画里看到的那样。小小的，戴着一顶小帽子。
Do you believe in them?
你相信它们吗？
Yes, of course.
是的，当然。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Have you seen any?
你见过吗？
No, I have not seen any.
没有，我没见过。
There's so many stories, and people talk a lot about them, so they must be true.
有太多的故事了，人们谈论了很多，所以它们一定是真的。
I think it's nice to believe it.
我觉得相信这一点很好。
That's one thing that I like about Iceland.
这就是我喜欢冰岛的一点。
It is that yearning quality. That sense that it's at least nice to believe in hidden people that comes up again and again, even from a skeptic like Arni. The tales are a vestige of a pre-urban Iceland. They are a holdover from what came before. And the physical record of what came before seems to be disappearing at an alarming rate in Reykjavik. Everywhere I look there is new construction. And the city itself, despite being over 200 years old, is counter-intuitively new. I had been expecting a baby Amsterdam, whole spun sugar, northern European architecture, spires, gables, cobblestones.
那是一种渴望的品质。那种“相信隐身人至少是一件好事”的感觉一次又一次地出现，即使是像阿尼这样的怀疑论者也不例外。这些故事是前城市化冰岛的残余。它们是过去留下的东西。而且在雷克雅未克，过去所留下的物理记录似乎正在以惊人的速度消失。我环顾四周，到处都是新的建筑。这座城市本身尽管已有200多年历史，但却反常地显得非常新。我原以为会看到一个小阿姆斯特丹，整个城市像是用糖做的，充满北欧建筑风格，有尖塔、山墙和鹅卵石。
Reykjavik, however, turns out to be very Bauhaus kind of town. A lot of it looks not a little like a vast Audi dealership. Urbanization is intrinsically a violent process. It elicits a terrified nostalgia and perhaps a little bit of guilt. It makes us want to hold fast to what we feel we are destroying. This was at the heart of the arts and crafts movement of the 19th century, with its concentration on handiwork, on the non-industrial.
然而，雷克雅未克最终却是一个非常包豪斯风格的小镇。很多地方看起来简直就像一个巨大的奥迪经销商展厅。城市化本质上是一个暴力的过程。它引发了一种恐怖的怀旧感，或许还有一点负罪感。它让我们想要紧紧抓住我们觉得自己正在摧毁的东西。这是19世纪工艺美术运动的核心，其重点在于手工制作，在于非工业化。
In part, it what's made the Brothers Grimm decide to compile their oral ethnography of indigenous German folktales when they did. Even Martha Stewart's monomaniacal obsession with the homemade is born of a similar impulse, an impulse to, if not stop time, at least slow it down some and preserve some sense of the past.
在某种程度上，这正是格林兄弟决定在当时汇编德国本土民间口头传说集的原因。即使是玛莎·斯图尔特那种对自制品的狂热执着，也源于类似的冲动，一种如果不停止时间，至少也要让时间慢下来，并保留某种过去感觉的冲动。
We are here in the library now. We have about 5,000 different books about psychic and spiritual things and also on hidden people. And here we have a classroom, and there are some students here studying as you can hear.
我们现在在图书馆。我们有大约5000本关于心理和精神事物的书，也有关于隐身人的书。这里有一个教室，正如你所听到的，里面有一些学生在学习。
This is Magnus Skarpheoinsson, founder of The Elf School, which offers four hour courses, mostly for foreigners. The course includes a bus tour of the main elf and hidden people sites in Reykjavik, followed by a typical Icelandic coffee and pancake breakfast. It's all pleasantly low rent. The sign on the door is a paper flyer with a drawing of a cartoon ghost.
这位是马格努斯·斯卡菲恩松，精灵学校的创始人，提供四小时的课程，主要是为外国人开设的。课程包括乘坐巴士参观雷克雅未克主要的精灵和隐身人遗址，随后享用典型的冰岛咖啡和煎饼早餐。这一切都让人感到轻松低调。门上的招牌是一张纸质传单，上面画着一个卡通幽灵。
Within that demographic of those who yearn for hidden people to exist, Magnus, it seems, yearns the most. But he covers this yearning with a veneer of science. He calls himself a scientist. He is convinced that with properly funded scientific research, the existence of hidden people could be proven conclusively. Magnus speaks about hidden people as an anthropologist or census taker might.
在那些渴望隐身人存在的群体中，马格努斯似乎是渴望得最深的一个。但他用一层科学的外衣掩盖了这种渴望。他称自己为科学家。他坚信，只要有充足资金支持的科学研究，隐身人的存在就能得到确凿的证明。马格努斯谈论隐身人就像一位人类学家或人口普查员可能会做的那样。
The main population of hidden people, he tells me, number some 20,000 to 30,000 individuals.
他告诉我，隐身人的主要人口数量在2万到3万之间。
I just would love to see them. Especially I would be wanting to see them and being invited to one cliff. Because I would ask 5,000 questions inside there. Where did you get the carpet? Where did you get the table? Where did you get the stove? Where did you get this? Have you been abroad? That's probably the reason why they haven't invited me.
我真希望能见到他们。我特别希望能见到他们并被邀请去一个悬崖里。因为我会问里面5000个问题。地毯是从哪儿买的？桌子是从哪儿买的？炉子从哪儿买的？这个东西是从哪儿来的？你们出过国吗？这可能就是他们没邀请我的原因。
It clearly rankles him a little bit that Erla Steffansdottir, a piano teacher and one of Iceland's most noted elf communicators, claims she has been seeing elves and hidden people her whole life. Magnus has led me to believe that my chances of meeting Erla would be slim to none. That she is difficult. That she will not be helpful. That she traffics in arbitrary rivalries. But when I call without having to push, she tells me to come the next day at 4 o'clock.
很明显，钢琴老师、冰岛最著名的精灵沟通者之一埃拉·斯特凡斯多蒂尔声称她一生都在看精灵和隐身人，这让他有点恼火。马格努斯让我觉得见到埃拉的机会微乎其微。她说她很难搞。她不会帮忙的。她卷入了随意的竞争。但当我打电话时，不需要多费口舌，她就让我第二天下午4点过去。
Erla's maps of hidden people sites around Iceland are on sale in tourist shops in Reykjavik. I was expecting a Stevie Nicks type, wild hair, clanking jewelry, a tatterdemalion velvet cape, cats. Instead, I found a friendly if somewhat shy woman in her 40s living in a lovely apartment on the top floor of a Reykjavik townhouse with a bay window. Erla's house is decorated in the tasteful middle class aesthetic one might expect of a piano teacher-- landscape paintings, old furniture. Erla's friend, Bjork [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is there to help translate Things began a little awkwardly.
埃拉关于冰岛各地隐身人遗址的地图在雷克雅未克的旅游商店里有售。我本以为会见到一个像史蒂薇·尼克斯那样的人，狂野的头发，叮当作响的珠宝，破烂的丝绒斗篷，还有猫。相反，我发现她是一位40多岁、友好但有些害羞的女性，住在雷克雅未克联排别墅顶层的一个可爱公寓里，带着飘窗。埃拉的房子装修得非常有品位，符合中产阶级的审美，就像你期望钢琴老师家里的那样——挂着风景画，摆着旧家具。埃拉的朋友比约克在那里帮忙翻译。事情开始得有点尴尬。
When did you first see or realize that you could see hidden people?
你是什么时候第一次看到或意识到你能看到隐身人的？
It's a little stupid to ask when I see.
问我什么时候看到，这有点傻。
Erla says she has always been able to see the various beings who live in dimensions other than our own. Like that one right there she says, indicating a place on the coffee table beside a Danish modern glass ashtray. She then catches herself. Oh, that's right. You can't see it. She shakes her head slightly, amused at her forgetfulness that others do not possess her gift. It's a somewhat disingenuous moment, like when your friend, newly back from a semester in Paris says to you, it's like, uhm, oh, I forget the English word, how you say fromage?
埃拉说她一直都能看到生活在我们维度之外的各种生物。她说，就像那一个，指着咖啡桌旁边丹麦现代风格玻璃烟灰缸旁的一个地方。然后她意识到自己失言了。“哦，对了。你看不到它。”她轻轻摇了摇头，对自己的健忘感到好笑，忘了别人并不拥有她的天赋。这有点虚伪，就像你的朋友从巴黎留学归来后对你说：“它就像，呃，哦，我忘了那个英文词，法语怎么说来着？”
When I am playing on the piano they come. They are everywhere.
当我弹钢琴时，它们就来了。它们无处不在。
The music attracts them, so when she's playing they come. They gather around her.
音乐吸引它们，所以当她弹奏时它们就来了。它们聚集在她周围。
Are they moving around right here?
它们就在这儿走来走去吗？
[SPEAKING ICELANDIC]
[讲冰岛语]
One sits there. Two are walking over here. One is sitting there.
一个坐在那儿。两个在那边走过来。一个正坐在那儿。
I am suddenly overcome with a completely inappropriate urge, the barely suppressed impulse to slam my hand down on the coffee table really, really hard, right where she's pointing. Obviously, I refrain from doing so.
我突然产生了一种完全不恰当的冲动，一种几乎无法抑制的冲动，想用力地在那张咖啡桌上猛拍一下，就在她指的地方。当然，我忍住了。
[SPEAKING ICELANDIC]
[讲冰岛语]
She said, in every home there's a dwarf or an elf who is like the size of a three-year-old child. Every home has it and with those beings, you can communicate.
她说，每个家里都有一个像三岁小孩那么大的矮人或精灵。每个家都有，而且你可以和那些生物交流。
So every house has a house elf? In New York City too?
那么每个房子都有一个家养小精灵？纽约市也有吗？
So you have one in your home too.
所以你家里也有一个。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，没错。
But Bjork points out that house elves are a privilege, not a right. When the energy of a given house gets too negative, she says, when there is drinking or fighting, the elves will leave. Suddenly, mysticism, new age philosophy, recovery speak, and elves our conflated as one.
但比约克指出，家养小精灵是一种特权，而不是权利。她说，当一个房子的能量变得太负面时，当家里有酗酒或吵架时，精灵就会离开。突然间，神秘主义、新时代哲学、康复理念和精灵全都混在一起了。
Erla says that elves are a manifestation of nature. They are inherently good. Without them we were choke on our own pollution. There's almost no more urban point of view of nature than this pastoral idyllic one. Humankind bad, nature good. As in, drinking and fighting bad. The elves and flowers good. But it's a false dichotomy. After all, following this logic Sistine Chapel bad, Ebola virus good?
埃拉说精灵是大自然的显现。它们本质上是善良的。没有它们，我们会被自己的污染窒息。这种田园诗般自然观的观点，几乎没有比这更城市化的了。人类是坏的，大自然是好的。就像说酗酒和吵架是不好的，精灵和花朵是好的。但这是一种错误的二分法。毕竟，按照这个逻辑，西斯廷教堂是坏的，埃博拉病毒是好的吗？
The next day on my way to Keflavik Airport, I get a sustained look at the landscape outside the city. In the weak afternoon light, it is an unrelievedly monochromatic view. Flat, vaguely undulating, black rock, cracked all over with a tracery of fissures. To the right, the vast gray sea and to the left, in the distance, the strange hills, looking like whales resting on their sides. Each one isolated against the horizon.
第二天在去凯夫拉维克机场的路上，我持续地观察了城市外面的风景。在午后微弱的光线下，这是一个单调得令人绝望的景色。平坦、隐约起伏、黑色的岩石，到处都是裂缝。右边是广阔的灰色海洋，左边远处是奇异的山丘，看起来就像侧卧的鲸鱼，每一座都孤立在天际线上。
At one point, we drive within half a mile of the perfect cone of a young volcano. The rain falls all the while.
在某个点，我们驱车经过距离一座年轻火山的完美圆锥体不到半英里远的地方。雨一直下个不停。
In A Midsummer Night's Dream, Shakespeare describes the Athenian wood that lies just beyond the gates of the city as "A place where the wild thyme blows, where oxlips and the nodding violet grows. Quite over-canopied with lush woodbine, with sweet musk-roses and eglantine."
在《仲夏夜之梦》中，莎士比亚将位于城市门外的雅典森林描述为：“野百里香生长之处，黄花九轮草和点头紫罗兰生长之处。被茂密的忍冬藤、香甜的麝香玫瑰和野蔷薇所覆盖。”
It's crowded in that Athenian forest. You can't take two steps without having to push aside some blossom-heavy branch concealing countless magical fairies. By contrast, Icelanders were frequently all alone in the wilderness. The spaces yawn open, wide and disconnected. And it is our nature to connect, to create for ourselves a fully formed community where none exists. We are hardwired for it. As Oberon says, "The poet's eye, in fine frenzy rolling, doth glance from heaven to earth, from earth to heaven. And as imagination bodies forth, the form of things unknown, the poet's pen turns them into shapes and gives to airy nothing, a local habitation and a name."
那片雅典森林很拥挤。你走不出两步，就不得不拨开那些藏着无数神奇仙女的沉重花枝。相比之下，冰岛人常常独自置身荒野。空间空旷、广阔且互不连接。而建立联系、在没有社区的地方为自己创造一个完整的社区，是我们的本性。我们天生就有这种倾向。正如奥伯伦所说：“诗人的眼睛在狂乱的旋转中，从天到地，从地到天一瞥。当想象力勾勒出未知事物的形态时，诗人的笔将它们变成形状，并赋予虚无以地方、居所和名称。”
David Rakoff lives in New York, where despite his best efforts, he does not believe in magic. He's put a version of this story into his upcoming book, which is called Fraud.
大卫·拉科夫住在纽约，尽管他尽了最大努力，但他并不相信魔法。他把他这个故事的一个版本写进了他即将出版的书里，书名叫《欺诈》。
Act two. OK, so let's review. In Iceland, the government moves massive boulders because a handful of citizens believe that invisible hidden people live near those boulders. As we look around the world, not every city government is quite as accommodating of people's idiosyncratic wishes. Take this example.
第二幕。好吧，让我们回顾一下。在冰岛，政府移动巨大的巨石，因为少数公民相信隐形隐身人住在巨石附近。当我们环顾世界时，并非每个城市政府都像这样迁就人们的独特愿望。看看这个例子。
This is Rudy Giuliani, back again on the air. Now we're going to go to David in Oceanside.
这是鲁迪·朱利安尼，再次回到直播中。现在我们去听听大洋赛区大卫的电话。
Hello, Mr. Guiliani. We speak again.
你好，朱利安尼先生。我们又通话了。
Hi David.
你好，大卫。
Let me introduce myself again. David Guthartz, executive president of New York Ferrets' Right Advocacy. Last week when we spoke, you said a very disparaging remark to me that I should get a life. That was very unprofessional of you. Here we're trying to get something seriously done-- without you talking over me-- we're trying to get something very seriously done.
让我再次介绍一下我自己。大卫·古萨茨，纽约雪貂权利倡导组织执行主席。上周我们通话时，你对我说了非常轻蔑的话，让我去“找点正事做”。这太不专业了。我们在这里努力争取做成一些严肃的事情——别打断我——我们正努力争取做成一些非常严肃的事情。
David, you're on my show. I have the right to talk over you.
大卫，你在我的节目上。我有权打断你。
But here's the thing. You talked over me the last time.
但关键是，上次你打断我了。
OK, let's just stop the tape right there. They're on my show and-- so I guess I have the right to talk over them. This is the mayor of New York, of course. This was recorded July 23, 1999. He was doing his weekly call-in show on WABC AM.
好吧，我们就把磁带停在这里。他们在我的节目上——所以我猜我有权打断他们。这当然是纽约市长。这是1999年7月23日录制的。他当时正在WABC广播电台做每周连线节目。
This exchange made the news because the mayor got so exercised about whether New Yorkers should be allowed to keep ferrets in their homes. Mr. Giuliani, of course, is famous for having transformed New York City. Sweeping everything, including the homeless people, off the streets. In his view, New York versus ferrets is just a reiteration of the basic question, civilization versus chaos. And he knows where he stands.
这次交流上了新闻，因为市长对于是否应该允许纽约客在家中饲养雪貂感到非常激动。朱利安尼先生当然以改造纽约市而闻名，他扫清了街道上的一切，包括无家可归者。在他看来，纽约市对抗雪貂只是文明对抗混乱这一基本问题的重申。他很清楚自己的立场。
If you follow the news very, very closely, you may have read about this exchange in the paper. Very few of us actually heard it. We decided to get a copy of the tape.
如果你非常、非常密切地关注新闻，你可能在报纸上读到过这次交流。很少有人真正听到过它。我们决定弄一份录音带。
David, you're on my show. I have the right to talk over you.
大卫，你在我的节目上。我有权打断你。
But here's the thing. You talked over me last time.
但关键是，上次你打断我了。
And the fact--
而且事实上——
We are trying to get--
我们正努力去——
David!
大卫！
--important issue taken care of where the city is violating state law. And I had asked you last week if you care about the law.
——把重要的问题处理好，纽约市违反了州法。我上周问过你，你在乎法律吗？
Yes, I do care about the law. I think you have totally and absolutely misinterpreted the law, because there's something deranged about you.
是的，我在乎法律。我认为你完全且绝对地曲解了法律，因为你有点精神错乱。
No there isn't, sir. The law states--
不，我没有，先生。法律规定——
The excessive concern that you have for ferrets is something you should examine with a therapist.
你对雪貂那种过度的关心是你应该去咨询心理医生处理的问题。
Sir, understand that-- well, first of all--
先生，请理解——好吧，首先——
Not with me.
不要跟我咨询。
--don't go insulting me again.
——不要再侮辱我了。
I'm not insulting you. I'm being honest with you. Maybe nobody in your life has ever been honest with you. But there's an incessant--
我没有侮辱你。我对你很坦诚。也许你生命中从来没有人对你坦诚过。但有一种不断的——
Sir, I happen to be more sane than you.
先生，我比你更理智。
David, there is--
大卫，这儿有——
First of all, let me explain to you something--
首先，让我跟你解释一些事——
There is a serious--
有一个严重的——
Mr. Guiliani.
朱利安尼先生。
David.
大卫。
Rudy.
鲁迪。
This conversation is over, David. Thank you. There is something really, really very sad about you. You need help. You need somebody to help you. This excessive concern with little weasels is a sickness. I'm sorry, that's my opinion. You don't have to accept it. There are probably very few people that would be as honest with you about that. But you should go consult a psychologist or a psychiatrist and have him help you with this excessive concern. How you are devoting your life to weasels.
这次谈话结束了，大卫。谢谢。你身上有一些真的、真的非常令人悲伤的地方。你需要帮助。你需要有人来帮你。这种对小鼬类的过度关心是一种病。我很抱歉，那是我的观点。你不必接受。可能很少有人会像我这样对你这么坦诚。但你应该去咨询心理学家或精神科医生，让他们帮你解决这种过度的关心。你竟然把一生都献给了鼬鼠。
There are people in this city and in this world that need a lot of help. Something has gone wrong with you. Your compulsion about it, your excessive concern with it, is the sign of something wrong in your personality. I do not mean to be insulting. I'm trying to be honest with you, and I'm trying to give you advice for your own good.
在这个城市和这个世界上，有人需要很多帮助。你出了问题。你的这种强迫症，你对它的过度关心，是你人格中出问题的迹象。我无意冒犯。我只是试图对你坦诚，我是在为你着想给你建议。
You have a sickness. And I know it's hard for you to accept that, because you hang on to this sickness. And it's your shield, it's your whatever. You've got to go to somebody who understands this a lot better than I do. And I know you're real angry at me and you're going to attack me. But actually, you're angry at yourself. You're afraid of what I'm raising with you. You need help. And please get it.
你有病。我知道你很难接受这一点，因为你紧抓着这种病不放。这是你的盾牌，或者什么的。你必须去找一个比我更了解这一点的人。我知道你真的对我感到愤怒，你会攻击我。但实际上，你是在对自己感到愤怒。你害怕我向你提出的问题。你需要帮助。请去寻求帮助吧。
Now we're going to move onto Richard in the Bronx.
现在我们要去听听布朗克斯区理查德的电话。
Hello?
喂？
Yes, Richard.
是的，理查德。
Yes. Mr. Mayor, my name is Richard--
是的。朱利安尼市长，我叫理查德——
Rudolph Giuliani, mayor of New York City. At the time when we first broadcast these comments on our program, he was a candidate for the US Senate. When we contacted the democrat who eventually won that senate seat, Hillary Rodham Clinton, to find out her stance on the ferret issue, her staff never returned the call.
鲁道夫·朱利安尼，纽约市长。当我们第一次在节目中播出这些评论时，他还是美国参议院议员候选人。当我们联系最终赢得参议院席位的民主党人希拉里·罗德姆·克林顿，想了解她对雪貂问题的立场时，她的工作人员从未回复过电话。
[MUSIC- "RAT TRAP" BY BOOMTOWN RATS]
[音乐- “捕鼠器” by 城镇老鼠乐队]
Coming up, a story involving Scott Carrier, some explosives, a newspaper reporter, a bunch of kids, and a rattlesnake. Also, can a hamster come back from the grave to haunt you? And other urgent, yet curiously unanswered questions, in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个涉及斯科特·卡里尔、一些炸药、一名报社记者、一群孩子和一条响尾蛇的故事。另外，仓鼠死后会回来缠着你吗？还有其他紧迫而又好奇地悬而未决的问题，一分钟后继续收听国际公共广播电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we chose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program is about those cracks and crevices where nature insinuates itself into environments that are completely man-made, and what that does to people.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然都会选择一个主题，并带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目是关于那些大自然渗入完全人造环境的裂缝，以及这对人们的影响。
We've arrived at act three of our program. Act three, Church of the Latter Day Snakes. This is the story of people who want more of nature than the chance to occasionally hike and goof around outside. These are people who bump up against the question, how far should we go in our love of the great outdoors? Can you bring it inside the house? Scott Carrier tells this story from Salt Lake City.
我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕：《后期圣徒之蛇教》。这是一个关于那些想要大自然带来更多东西的人的故事，而不只是偶尔去户外徒步玩耍的机会。这些人面临一个问题：我们对户外运动的热爱应该走多远？你能把它带进屋里吗？斯科特·卡里尔从盐湖城讲述了这个故事。
We had already brought home the dynamite and blasting caps we found abandoned in the gully by the freeway. Now we prepared to set out for the foothills to capture a rattlesnake. Our father had not let us keep the explosives, and I doubted he would allow a rattlesnake in the house, but my brother, my older brother, had seen the snake and knew where it lived, and he wanted it. He needed it, to study for science.
我们已经把在高速公路旁的小溪沟里发现的废弃炸药和雷管带回了家。现在，我们准备出发去山脚捕捉响尾蛇。父亲没让我们留下那些炸药，我怀疑他也不会允许响尾蛇进屋，但我哥哥，我那个哥哥，见过那条蛇，知道它住在哪里，他想要它。他需要它，为了科学研究。
He'd read a book on herpetology and had made a snake catching stick by carving a small fork at one end to pin down the snake's head against the ground. We'd practice with the stick-- my brother, myself, and my best friend, Lenny-- jabbing at imaginary snakes in the backyard. We had a pocket knife sharpened on a whetstone to use to cut open the wound and suck out the poison in case one of us got bit. We felt pretty sure we knew what we were doing.
他读过一本关于爬行动物学的书，做了一个捕捉蛇的棍子，在一端刻了一个小叉子，用来把蛇头钉在地上。我们用那个棍子练习过——我哥哥、我自己，还有我最好的朋友莱尼——戳向院子里想象中的蛇。我们有一把在磨刀石上磨利的折叠刀，用来切开伤口并吸出毒液，以防我们中有人被咬。我们觉得很确定自己知道在做什么。
My brother said, we'll keep it in the cage in my room downstairs and feed it mice and toads. As long as we keep it a secret, everything will be fine. He said this looking at me, because the dynamite and blasting caps had also been a secret until I blabbed the whole story one night at dinner.
我哥哥说，我们会把它养在楼下卧室的笼子里，喂它老鼠和癞蛤蟆。只要我们保守秘密，一切都会好起来的。他说这话时看着我，因为炸药和雷管的事在晚饭时我没把故事全盘托出之前也是个秘密。
How we found the wooden crates in the cottonwoods along the river. How we recognized the contents because, in those days, they were public service commercials on television during the cartoons, warning kids never to touch blasting caps that might be lying around discarded or forgotten. Kids had died. Kids had had their arms blown off, their faces removed, and so on. So when we found the boxes it was like finding buried treasure. We weren't going to touch the contents, but we weren't going to leave them there either.
我们是如何在河边的棉白杨树丛中发现那些木箱的。我们是如何认出里面东西的，因为在那个年代，电视上在播放卡通片时会有公共服务广告，警告孩子们永远不要触摸可能被遗弃或遗忘的雷管。有孩子因此死了，有孩子被炸断了手臂，脸部毁容等等。所以当我们发现那些盒子时，就像发现了埋藏的宝藏。我们没打算动里面的东西，但也不想把它们留在那里。
We were careful, very careful, carrying them home. Walking slowly, smoothly. One false step and it would be all she wrote. Kabloom, sayonara, kiss our own sweet asses goodbye. We brought the boxes home and hid them in the basement where they'd be safe, thinking that there would be endless possibilities. I told this story at dinner hoping that our dad would recognize these possibilities, but he immediately called the cops, and they came and took it all away. Then the next day, the reporter showed up and we were the paper, and it just didn't come out at all like I thought it would.
我们很小心，非常小心地把它们带回家。走得很慢、很稳。只要踏错一步就全完了。砰的一声，撒由那拉，跟我们可爱的小命说再见吧。我们把盒子带回家，藏在地下室里觉得很安全，认为会有无限的可能。我在晚饭时讲了这个故事，希望父亲能意识到这些可能性，但他立刻打了报警电话，他们来了，把东西全收走了。第二天，记者来了，我们上了报纸，事情的发展和我预想的完全不同。
I admitted it was a mistake to talk about the dynamite. I said I'd learned my lesson, and I swore I would not say anything ever about the rattlesnake.
我承认谈论炸药是一个错误。我说我吸取了教训，并誓言绝不会提起关于响尾蛇的事。
Do you swear to God, my friend Lenny said.
你向上帝发誓吗？我的朋友莱尼说。
There is no God, my brother said. Swear on your honor.
没有上帝，我哥哥说。以你的荣誉发誓。
I swear to God. I swear on my honor, I said. I can keep a secret. But we all knew that I couldn't. I was the type of kid who would try to wrap the truth tightly inside my body only to have it eventually emerge from my mouth, like a hairy moth from a cocoon.
我向上帝发誓。我以我的荣誉发誓，我说。我能保守秘密。但我们都知道我做不到。我属于那种会试图把真相紧紧包裹在体内，最后却还是会像从茧里爬出的毛茸茸的飞蛾一样脱口而出的那种孩子。
We headed out with our knapsacks, the three of us, down the street of our brand new subdivision on the far eastern edge of town, next to the foothills of the Wasatch Mountains, a place of natural forces, the line where civilization ended and the wilderness began.
我们三个背着背包出发了，走在城镇东侧边缘新建的住宅区街道上，紧邻瓦萨奇山脉的山脚，那里是自然力量的所在，是文明终结、荒野开始的分界线。
Some of the homes in the subdivision were newly occupied, and some were still under construction with piles of scrap wood in the yards, the asphalt black and smooth, the sidewalks and driveways white and shiny and floating six inches above the native sand and gravel, waiting for sprinklers, topsoil, and sod. We cut through a neighbor's backyard, jumped the fence, and then crawled through a three foot diameter drainage pipe under the freeway on-ramp, and we are out of the city walking up into the scrub brush.
住宅区里的一些房子是新入住的，有些还在建设中，院子里堆着碎木块，柏油路面又黑又平，人行道和车道又白又亮，悬浮在原生沙砾之上六英寸，等待着洒水系统、表土和草皮。我们穿过邻居的后院，跳过栅栏，钻过高速公路匝道下直径三英尺的排水管，出了城，向灌木丛走去。
We didn't know it then, but the entire city was, and still is, surrounded by rattlesnakes. The Salt Lake Valley is shaped like a bull 20 miles in diameter with the Salt Lake itself resting like a pool of mercury at the bottom, and the peaks of the mountains forming the rim 7,000 feet above. The rattlesnakes live at a particular narrow band of elevation on the inside of this bull and their habitat, their niche, is continuous around the contour, like a poisonous belt. A deadly ring of serpents, constricting the City of Saints. As if the battle for the Garden of Eden were still ongoing, which I know the Mormon's believe, and maybe the snakes do as well.
我们当时不知道，但整个城市一直被响尾蛇包围着。盐湖谷的形状像一个直径20英里的碗，盐湖本身就像底部的一池水银，山峰在上方7000英尺处形成边缘。响尾蛇生活在这个碗内侧的一个特定狭窄海拔带，它们的栖息地，它们的生态位，在轮廓线上是连续的，就像一条有毒的腰带。一道致命的蛇环，勒紧了圣徒之城。仿佛伊甸园之战仍在进行，我知道摩门教徒是这么相信的，也许蛇也是这么认为的。
But all we knew then was that my brother had seen one rattlesnake and knew where it lived in a crack in an outcrop of rocks.
但那时我们只知道哥哥见过一条响尾蛇，知道它住在岩石露头的一道裂缝里。
Walking up to the rock outcrop, Lenny was telling us how his cousin, Marlin, had told him that some scientists from the University of Utah had implanted radioactive pellets in the stomachs of some rattlesnakes, and then released them in the foothills. Only to discover them months later down by the Great Salt Lake. That's 15 miles, my brother said. Rattlesnakes don't migrate. How would they get there? By sliding along the streets? They'd get run over by cars.
走到岩石露头时，莱尼告诉我们他的表弟马林说，犹他大学的一些科学家在几条响尾蛇的胃里植入了放射性颗粒，然后把它们放生在山脚下。结果几个月后在盐湖城附近发现了它们。那有15英里远，我哥哥说。响尾蛇不会迁徙。它们怎么会到那儿？顺着街道滑过去？它们会被车压死的。
That's just it, Lenny said. The scientists couldn't figure it out either. Until a woman was taking a leak in a toilet and got bit in the butt and died. That's when the scientists realized the snakes were in the sewers.
就是这样，莱尼说。科学家们也搞不明白。直到一个女人在厕所小便时被咬到了屁股死掉了。那时候科学家们才意识到蛇已经在下水道里了。
That's ridiculous, my brother said. Rattlesnakes don't like water. They don't swim in sewers. They like to stay in one place and sit in the sun. Lenny said, well, that's what the scientists said. It's not true, my brother said. You don't know that much, Lenny said. You may have read a book, but you're not a scientist. Not yet anyway. Well, my brother said, I know enough to know your cousin's lying to you.
这太荒谬了，我哥哥说。响尾蛇不喜欢水。它们不会在下水道里游泳。它们喜欢呆在一个地方晒太阳。莱尼说，好吧，科学家就是这么说的。这不可能是真的，我哥哥说。你懂的不多，莱尼说。你可能读过书，但你不是科学家。还没到时候呢。好吧，我哥哥说，我够了解你表弟在撒谎。
When we got close to the rock outcrop, we got down on our hands and knees and crawled to a position where we could look down and see the rattlesnake, right where my brother had said it would be, lying in the sun just outside an off-width crack. It was a little rattlesnake, maybe only two feet long. My brother took the stick and slowly inched his way around to where he was just underneath it. And then he jumped up and jabbed at it. He missed and the snake lunged at him, and he jumped back and fell over. And then he got up and jabbed again. This time, pinning down the snake's tail. It whirled and lunged to bite his hand and my brother jumped back again, releasing his hold.
当我们靠近岩石露头时，我们跪在地上爬到可以看到响尾蛇的位置，就在我哥哥说它会待的地方，躺在裂缝外晒太阳。那是一条小响尾蛇，也许只有两英尺长。我哥哥拿起棍子，慢慢地挪到它正下方。然后他跳起来刺向它。他没刺中，蛇猛地扑向他，他跳回去摔倒了。然后他站起来再次刺击。这一次，钉住了蛇尾。它回转身体猛扑想要咬他的手，我哥哥再次跳开，释放了压制。
Lenny and I were on our feet yelling, get it, get it, get it. But the snake was quick and slid back into the crack out of reach. The whole thing took maybe five seconds, but I'd never seen anything like it. We were jumping up and down, jumping nearly out of our bodies, wild and insane with excitement.
我和莱尼站起来大喊：抓住它，抓住它，抓住它。但蛇很快，滑回了裂缝里，够不到了。整个过程可能只花了五秒钟，但我从没见过那样的景象。我们跳上跳下，几乎跳出了自己的身体，因兴奋而狂野癫狂。
We waited for the snake to come back out of the crack, but we'd scared it pretty bad. And then Lenny and I couldn't be quiet, even though my brother kept telling us to shut up. He was mad at it, and even more upset with himself for missing his chance. I didn't care. My brother had abandoned his fear and faced death, or at least severe injury. In a way we'd seen in movies and read about in books, but had never experienced firsthand. My brother was brave. And if my brother was brave, then maybe I could be brave. And I knew then I wanted to be brave more than anything else in the world.
我们等蛇再从裂缝里出来，但我们吓坏它了。我和莱尼吵吵闹闹的，尽管我哥哥一直让我们闭嘴。他很生气，对自己错失机会感到更沮丧。我不在乎。我哥哥放弃了恐惧，直面死亡，或者至少是严重的伤害。这是一种我们只在电影里看过、在书里读过，却从未亲身经历过的方式。我哥哥很勇敢。如果我哥哥很勇敢，那么也许我也可以勇敢。我知道那时我比世界上任何东西都更想变得勇敢。
So at that point my life changed. All our exploits of ringing doorbells, getting chased by the security guard on the golf course, throwing snowballs at cars, all these seemed childish. The true object, the true endeavor in life, became the pursuit of the bold initiative. The coming face to face with fear in whatever form or manifestation, and doing battle with it.
就在那一刻，我的人生改变了。我们之前按门铃、被高尔夫球场保安追赶、向汽车扔雪球的所有冒险，看起来都很幼稚。生命中真正的目标、真正的追求，变成了对大胆行动的追求。不管以什么形式或表现方式，直面恐惧，并与之搏斗。
We waited for the snake for a while and then gave up and went home, telling ourselves that we'd come back the next day. But we never did, and maybe it's just as well. Some things don't belong in the house. Our father would have said that, and now at least I can see his point.
我们等了一会儿蛇，然后放弃了，回家了，告诉自己第二天再回来。但我们再也没去过，也许这样也好。有些东西不属于家里。我父亲会这么说的，现在至少我明白了。
My brother, however, has never really given in on this. He continued to hunt and catch snakes as a kid. Not rattlesnakes, but plenty of other ones. And he did grow up to become a scientist. A biologist, in fact.
然而，我哥哥在这方面一直没有放弃。他小时候继续猎捕蛇。不是响尾蛇，但有很多其他的。而且他确实长大成了一名科学家。事实上，是一名生物学家。
Just last week, at the age of 43, after his wife brought home their firstborn son, he put up a six foot high chain link fence, the kind you normally see outside, right across the middle of their kitchen to keep his pack of wild, neurotic lab dogs from jumping the baby. The dogs have already torn up the grass in the backyard, so it's all mud and dirt. One attacked a neighbor's cat.
就在上周，在他43岁那年，他的妻子把刚出生的儿子带回家后，他在厨房中间竖起了一道六英尺高的铁丝栅栏，那种你通常在外面看到的栅栏，用来防止他那群狂野、神经质的实验犬扑向婴儿。狗已经把后院的草皮撕烂了，全变成了泥土。其中一只还袭击了邻居的猫。
I haven't actually seen the fence yet. My dad told me about it. But I can picture it. The baby on the kitchen floor, sucking on a pacifier. The five dogs sitting just on the other side of the fence, staring intently at a meal they will never enjoy.
我还没真正见过那道栅栏。是我爸告诉我的。但我可以想象出来。婴儿在厨房地板上，吮吸着安抚奶嘴。五只狗坐在栅栏的另一边，专注地盯着它们永远无法享用的美味。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. His first book, Running After Antelope , will be in stores any day now.
斯科特·卡里尔，盐湖城。他的第一本书《追逐羚羊》很快就会上架销售。
Act four, God Bless the Hamster Who Has His Own. Is it right to bring nature in the house, and then put it into the hands of children? Nearly everybody you meet has the story of some pet, usually a gerbil or a hamster, a tiny fish or an amphibian, where something went terribly, terribly wrong. For the pet, anyway. And if this story didn't happen to your friends, it happened to their brothers or sisters. It is sadly common.
第四幕：《上帝保佑拥有宠物的仓鼠》。把大自然带进家里，然后把它交给孩子们，这正确吗？你遇到的几乎每个人都有关于宠物的故事，通常是沙鼠或仓鼠，或者是小鱼或两栖动物，哪里出了非常非常严重的问题。至少对宠物来说是这样。如果这个故事没发生在你的朋友身上，也会发生在他们的兄弟姐妹身上。这很常见，令人悲伤。
So when I was six years old and my younger brother was four, we were at the only hamburger place in my hometown. And he had his pet toad in his left hand, and he had his hamburger is his right hand. And unfortunately, he got his hands mixed up.
我六岁，弟弟四岁时，我们在家乡唯一的汉堡店。他左手拿着宠物癞蛤蟆，右手拿着汉堡。不幸的是，他把手弄混了。
I had a turtle who died in the fall, and they buried it in the backyard. And then, the following spring they were planting bulbs in the area of the yard where the turtle was and they dug it up and it was alive. It had been hibernating.
我有一只乌龟在秋天死了，他们把它埋在后院。结果第二年春天，他们在埋乌龟的地方种球茎时把它挖了出来，它竟然还活着。它一直在冬眠。
I don't know. I didn't start out really wanting to kill my fish, but I was cleaning their tank and they were in these little Cool Whip containers. And I just didn't like the way that they looked in the little containers. And then, I don't know, I just flushed them all down the toilet.
我不知道。我刚开始并不是真的想害死我的鱼，但我正在清理鱼缸，它们待在这些小的酷派冰淇淋容器里。我就是不喜欢它们在那些小容器里的样子。然后，我不知道，我就把它们全冲进厕所了。
When Starlee Kine went out talking to people about this, there was one girl, a high school freshman here in Chicago, who seemed just somehow to stand out when it came to these stories.
当斯塔利·凯恩出去找人聊这件事时，这里芝加哥有一位高中新生，当谈到这些故事时，她显得格外突出。
I got my first hamster and I named her Bubbles. Then I had a boy, and he was brown and white. And I named him White Sox. And they had six kids, but she killed them. I don't know. They were smushed. And then she had another set, and she bit one's head off. She smushed four of them, and she ate the other one. But shortly after that, she was getting thin. I noticed that she was getting thin. But we didn't feed her like her hamster food. She always ate table food. It was like, shrimp, lobster, crab, potato chips. They drunk pop, juice, pudding, jello. I mean, like everything except for tofu and sushi. Except for that.
我买了第一只仓鼠，叫它泡泡。然后我买了一只公的，棕白色的。我给它取名叫白袜。它们生了六只孩子，但她把它们杀死了。我不知道。它们被压扁了。后来她又生了一窝，她咬掉了其中一个的头。她压死了四只，还吃掉了另外一只。但那之后不久，她变得很瘦。我注意到她越来越瘦了。但我们没喂她仓鼠粮。她总是吃桌上的食物。比如虾、龙虾、螃蟹、薯片。它们喝汽水、果汁、布丁、果冻。我是说，除了豆腐和寿司，她什么都吃。除了那些。
I don't know if that would cause her to lose so much weight, but then one day we come home and she was real small. And then when she walked, she would like wobble. And one day me and my mom went to go see my brother. When we came back, she was dead. But I just threw her out. I didn't cry, but I just threw her out.
我不知道这是否会导致她瘦了这么多，但有一天我们回家，她变得特别小。当她走路时，她会摇摇晃晃的。有一天我和妈妈去见我哥哥。当我们回来时，她死了。我直接把她扔了。我没哭，直接扔了。
There were crayfish. I had some crayfish. And I was doing a project. Does pesticide have an affect on-- affect the growth on crayfish. And they ate blood worms. They were in my mom's freezer. And I didn't think she liked the idea of worms. Especially blood worms in the freezer. So I just took them out of the freezer and they all melted. It was blood and worms. It just melted.
还有小龙虾。我养过一些小龙虾。我在做一个项目。农药是否对小龙虾的生长有影响。它们吃血虫。它们在我妈的冷冻库里。我觉得她不喜欢有虫子的主意。特别是在冷冻库里放血虫。所以我把它们从冷冻库拿出来，它们全都化了。那是血和虫子。直接化了。
So what I did was-- it was like a big bag of blood worms. And I just dumped the whole thing in the tank. But then I overfed them and they died.
所以我做的是——那是一大袋血虫。我直接把整袋倒进了鱼缸里。但后来我喂得太多了，它们就死了。
I think I'm a pet killer. I don't know, because I had fish. My fish died. I had an amphibian. It died. A snail. The snail, he just kicked over too.
我觉得我就是个宠物杀手。我不知道，因为我养过鱼，我的鱼死了。我养过两栖动物，它死了。还有蜗牛，蜗牛也挂了。
After my other pets died, I told my brother and my neighbor, because they did a lot of bad stuff to them. Stuff like with the hot sauce and they used to just flick them in the nose, and they were like scared. So I said, they coming back to haunt you. And they actually got scared. They was like, don't say that. Don't say that. I was like, OK. You think I'm kidding? White Sox and Bubbles are coming back to y'all. And I'm not playing. I actually said I wished they would come back and just haunt them. I mean, I don't believe in all them ghosts and stuff, but I really want them to like just be scared.
我的其他宠物死后，我告诉了我哥哥和邻居，因为他们对它们做了很多坏事。比如用辣酱，他们过去常弹它们的鼻子，它们都吓坏了。所以我说，它们会回来缠着你们的。他们真的被吓到了。他们说，别这么说，别这么说。我说，好吧。你们以为我开玩笑？白袜和泡泡会回来缠着你们的。我不是在玩。我真的是说，我希望它们能回来缠着他们。我是说，我不相信那些鬼魂之类的东西，但我真的希望它们能让他们害怕。
The next pet I'm getting is a cat. This cat I'm going to get, it'll last, hopefully.
我要养的下一个宠物是一只猫。我要养这只猫，希望它能活得长久。
Typical high school freshman. She spoke with Starlee Kine.
典型的高中新生。她和斯塔利·凯恩谈过话。
[MUSIC- "RABBIT ACTION" BY JUNIOR THOMPSON & RABBIT ACTION]
[音乐- “兔子行动” by 朱尼尔·汤普森 & 兔子行动乐队]
Act five, Waiting For the End of the World. Well, we end our program today with this story of city life and the natural world coexisting peacefully-- sort of-- from Iggy Scam.
第五幕：《等待世界末日》。今天节目最后，我们以这个城市生活与自然世界和平共存的故事结束，虽然是以某种方式，来自伊吉·斯卡姆。
Take the 22 Fillmore bus in San Francisco south away from downtown to the end of the line. Get off there on the street of dead end railroad tracks where shopping carts drag in the fog. Go down the hill at 20th, past the empty lot on your right, past the old port complex on your left, and past the people living in their cars. When you get to the impound lot, you can see the bay.
在旧金山搭乘22路菲尔莫尔巴士，远离市中心向南，坐到终点站。在那条购物手推车在雾中拖曳的死胡同铁路线上走下来。沿20街下山，经过你右边的空地，经过左边的老港口建筑群，经过那些住在车里的人。当你到达车辆扣押场时，就能看到海湾了。
A walkway takes you past some abandoned warehouses and then abruptly stops at a fence at a no trespassing sign. There is a hole in the fence. On the other side is a rotten dock where on many nights you can find a mysterious group of men. They're not loading smuggled drugs or dumping bodies. They're fishing.
一条步道带你经过一些废弃的仓库，然后在“禁止擅入”的标志处突然停在栅栏前。栅栏上有一个洞。另一边是一个烂码头，许多晚上你都能发现一群神秘的人。他们不是在卸毒品或抛尸。他们在钓鱼。
The EPA says this rotten dock is one of the most polluted parts of the entire San Francisco Bay. The fishermen say it's a great place to catch halibut.
环保局说这个烂码头是整个旧金山湾污染最严重的区域之一。渔民们说这是钓大比目鱼的好地方。
It never fails. The more filthy and polluted a body of water in a city is, and the harder it is to access, the more guys you'll see fishing in it. And this isn't exactly scientific, but it seems like I'm seeing these urban fisherman more and more these days, hearing tales about them as I travel across the country. Men with poles, camped out on a railroad bridge over the Sacramento River. Dark figures with nets in a creek behind a Florida strip mall. And then there's those guys that congregate at the lake in Cleveland where warm water from an electricity plant guarantees good fishing even in the dead of winter.
屡试不爽。城市里的水体越脏、污染越严重，进入的难度越大，你看到的在那里钓鱼的人就越多。这算不上什么科学，但我觉得这些日子我越来越频繁地见到这些城市渔夫，在全国各地旅行时也听到了他们的故事。那些在萨克拉门托河的铁路桥上扎营的带着鱼竿的男人。佛罗里达州露天购物中心后面溪流中带着网的黑影。还有那些聚集在克利夫兰湖边的人，那里发电厂的温水保证了即使在隆冬也能钓到好鱼。
Once a trucker who picked me up when I was hitchhiking on I-75 spent the whole ride excitedly pointing out the roadside ditches where he'd often stop and catch fish.
曾经有一个卡车司机在我搭便车在75号州际公路上时，整个路程都在兴奋地指着路边的水沟，说他经常在那里停下来钓鱼。
Wherever a ripple breaks the placid, smooth surface of the constructed world, there have been fisherman in there to stick a hook in. Last year, I went out on the road looking for them.
无论哪里有涟漪打破了人造世界平稳、平坦的表面，总有渔夫在那里插上鱼钩。去年，我上路去寻找他们。
Miami. According to the WPA guide to Florida, early settlers to Biscayne Bay described waters, "Of every delicate shade of blue and green and tinged with every color of the spectrum. A sort of liquid light rather than water, so limped and brilliant is it. By all accounts, the fish are practically jumping into the boat."
迈阿密。根据WPA的佛罗里达指南，比斯坎湾的早期定居者这样描述水域：“蓝色和绿色的每一层细腻色调，被光谱中的每一种颜色渲染。与其说是水，不如说是一种液体光，清澈而灿烂。据各方说法，鱼儿几乎是跳进船里的。”
Today in Miami, it's still possible to live that early settler life. Orange, mango, and avocado trees, their branches heavy with fruit line many residential streets. And anyone with a machete can harvest the coconuts that grow wild, even on Flagler Street in the heart of downtown. And of course, despite the official health warnings about lead poisoning and the occasional leak of raw sewage into the bay, there's still plenty of fish.
今天在迈阿密，仍然可能过上那种早期定居者的生活。橘子树、芒果树和鳄梨树的枝头挂满了果实，排在许多住宅街道两旁。任何有砍刀的人都可以收获野生的椰子，即使在市中心腹地的弗拉格勒大街上也是如此。当然，尽管官方有关于铅中毒的健康警告，以及海湾偶尔发生的污水泄漏，但那里仍然有大量的鱼。
Most of the Miami River isn't publicly accessible. It runs through some boat yards and past residences. But still, I found a group of Latin guys fishing behind the old Shiners' temple. The had no fishing poles, but they had rigged up some pretty inspired do-it-yourself gear.
迈阿密河的大部分区域不对公众开放。它穿过一些造船厂和住宅区。但即便如此，我还是在老施纳神庙后面发现了一群钓鱼的拉丁裔家伙。他们没有鱼竿，但他们装备了一些相当有创意的DIY装置。
They had tied their lines through holes that they had punched through empty tall cans of malt liquor. And then they had wrapped the slack line around their cans. Then they unraveled their lines, held their cans with both hands, and waited.
他们把鱼线穿过空麦芽酒罐子上打的孔。然后把松弛的鱼线绕在罐子上。之后他们展开鱼线，双手拿着罐子，开始等待。
I walked up and said, [SPEAKING SPANISH]? One guy, rapidly rolling up his line said in a thick Spanish accent, yeah, I got one now. And sure enough, he pulled up a small, black and white spotted fish and laid it out on the concrete seawall.
我走过去说：“[讲西班牙语]？”一个人正飞快地收着线，用浓重的西班牙口音说：“是的，我刚钓到一条。”果然，他拉上来一条小小的黑白斑点鱼，放在水泥防波堤上。
All five of us gathered around it for a couple excited moments as a ripple of joy spread among us-- strangers. The guy who caught it declared, este for fry pan and dropped it into the bucket.
我们五个人都围着它，在陌生人之间蔓延开一阵兴奋的涟漪，大家感到了一阵喜悦。钓到鱼的人宣布：“这个用来煎！”然后把它扔进了桶里。
But even more sought after in Miami than the free spotted fish dinner are pink gold-- Biscayne Bay shrimp. Shrimping works like this.
但在迈阿密，比免费斑点鱼晚餐更令人垂涎的是粉红黄金——比斯坎湾虾。捕虾是这样进行的。
First you drive the boat to where you think the shrimp are going to be. Which is often in the warm water around the Turkey Point nuclear reactor south of Miami. Then you put the huge net in the water and drive the boat in a circle. Guys called pickers sort the stuff the net brings in and the shrimp go into buckets, and broken glass and tires go back into the water. It's illegal to sell the shrimp for anything but bait. But back on the docks, shrimp are like money. In Miami, it is still possible to buy car parts, new shoes, and tickets to basketball games with a bucket of shrimp.
首先你把船开到你认为虾会出现的地方。这通常是在迈阿密南部的土耳其角核反应堆周围的温水中。然后你把巨大的网放进水里，开着船转圈。被称为“捡虾人”的家伙负责分类网里带来的东西，虾进桶里，破碎的玻璃和轮胎回到水里。把虾卖钱是非法的，只能作为鱼饵。但在码头上，虾就像钱一样。在迈阿密，仍然可以用一桶虾买到汽车零件、新鞋和篮球比赛门票。
Detroit. The best way to see Detroit and all its glorious decay is to hop a fence and climb 14 flights of stairs to the roof of the abandoned train station just west of downtown. From this height, the city appears oddly green, as empty lots and wilderness slowly overtake the old metropolis. Trees grow out of the remains of crumbled houses. Seeing how nature has begun to reclaim the Motor City, I could only think of Henry Ford's famous line, "History is bunk."
底特律。观看底特律及其辉煌衰败的最好方法是翻过栅栏，爬上14层楼梯到达市中心西侧废弃火车站的屋顶。从这个高度看，城市显得出奇地绿，空地和荒野慢慢超过了旧都市。树木从崩塌房屋的废墟中长出来。看着大自然如何开始收回汽车城，我只能想起亨利·福特那句名言：“历史是胡扯。”
My friend, Mitchell, and I drove into Detroit on a bitterly cold morning. It was a lonely day in a lonely town. We went over to Riverside Park. I had been there once last summer when the sea wall was lined with guys drinking beer and tossing lines. On one side of the park there were the old-timers, listening to radios playing soul tunes. And on the other side, there were kids who had pulled up and left their car radios on, blasting bass.
我和朋友米切尔在一个寒冷的早晨开车进入底特律。在一个孤独的城市里，那是孤独的一天。我们去了滨江公园。去年夏天我曾去过那里，当时防波堤上站满了喝啤酒、甩鱼线的家伙。公园一侧是听着播放灵魂乐收音机的老人们。另一侧是开车过来留下车内收音机、把低音调到最大声的孩子们。
But today the park was frozen and empty. Mitchell and I took turns halfheartedly tossing our line into the slushy river. I wondered what kind of stuff you'd find at the bottom.
但今天公园结冰了，空无一人。米切尔和我轮流心不在焉地把鱼线甩进泥泞的河里。我想知道你在河底会发现什么样的东西。
Detroit makes today's obsession with the Millennium and the end of the world seem absurd. What are people talking about when they talk about the end of the world anyway? I've begun to realize that they're not talking about the actual destruction of the planet. They're talking about something more or like Detroit, the end of a certain way of life. The end of the world means no more CNN, no more air conditioning, no more ATM machines. And what of the scattered survivors who are already pushing their shopping carts around toxic devastated cities do while they wait for this end of the world? Go fishing, of course.
底特律使得今天人们对千年和世界末日的迷恋显得荒谬。当人们谈论世界末日时，他们到底在说什么？我开始意识到他们不是在谈论行星的实际毁灭。他们在谈论某种更像底特律的东西，某种生活方式的终结。世界末日意味着没有CNN，没有空调，没有自动取款机。而那些已经在有毒的荒废城市里推着购物手推车的零散幸存者，在等待世界末日时会做什么？当然是去钓鱼。
Chicago. My friend, [? Joaquin, ?] and I arrived in Chicago and decided to test my theory that the urban fishermen will instinctively find the most polluted waterway in any city. We got out a city map and traced the course of the Chicago River south into Lake Calumet, down near the Indiana border.
芝加哥。我和朋友[？华金？]抵达芝加哥，决定验证我的理论：城市渔夫会本能地找到任何城市里污染最严重的水道。我们拿出城市地图，追踪芝加哥河向南进入卡柳梅特湖的航线，一直到靠近印第安纳州边界的地方。
Lake Calumet has been used as a garbage dump and now serves as a port for ships navigating the St. Lawrence Seaway. On the map, it's surrounded by huge, mysterious, blank white spaces, the real life home of a sewage treatment facility, rail yards, a Ford Motor Company assembly plant, and the now mostly unused sites of an entire century's steel production.
卡柳梅特湖一直被当作垃圾填埋场，现在作为航行于圣劳伦斯海路船只的港口。在地图上，它被巨大的、神秘的空白白色空间所包围，那是污水处理设施、铁路调车场、福特汽车组装厂以及整个世纪钢铁生产现在基本未使用的遗址所在地。
The blank white space was exciting. It was like the [? Yee ?] dragons here of ancient maps. We hit the 94 and headed south. Nearing Lake Calumet, we past blackened smokestacks and iron pipes belching a sick blue flame and came to a dead end at the base of the lake. Getting out of the car, we saw that the road appeared to crumble directly into a river of thick black muck. The stench of sewage was overwhelming. On a fence was a sign that said sludge drying trough. Looking around at what appeared to be miles of such troughs, I thought, here we are, the blank white space on the map. And of course, at the tip of the dead end was a parked car and two guys drinking beer and fishing.
空白的白色空间令人兴奋。就像古代地图上的“此处有龙”。我们上了94号公路向南。靠近卡柳梅特湖时，我们经过了喷吐着恶心蓝色火焰的黑色烟囱和铁管，在湖底到达了死胡同。下车后，我们看到道路似乎直接崩塌进了一条厚厚的黑色烂泥河里。污水的恶臭令人窒息。栅栏上有一个标志写着“污泥干燥槽”。环顾四周那看起来绵延数英里的槽位，我想，这就是了，地图上的空白白色空间。当然，在死胡同的尽头是一辆停着的车和两个喝着啤酒、正在钓鱼的家伙。
[? Joaquin ?] went over and did the talking, but it wasn't much of an exchange. The two guys seemed nervous that we were going to try and steal their secret spot. Anything you can catch in Lake Michigan you can catch here, one guy said, as if that explained everything.
[？华金？]走过去说话，但这交流并不多。这两个家伙似乎很紧张，怕我们试图抢占他们的秘密地点。其中一个人说：“你在密歇根湖能钓到的任何东西，在这里也能钓到。”仿佛这就解释了一切。
Sure, why go all the way to Lake Michigan when you can just mosey on down to your neighborhood sludge drying trough.
当然，为什么要去那么远的密歇根湖，如果你可以直接漫步到你家附近的污泥干燥槽呢。
San Francisco. The city of San Francisco's official fishing pier is Pier 7 downtown. Every morning the benches at the end of the pier fill up with old Asian guys who come down the hill from Chinatown and spend all day there on the pier, doing some of the most breathtaking, artful fishing that I've ever seen. With absolute concentration, never saying a word, they race back and forth between three or four poles as they slowly fill their buckets with fish.
旧金山。旧金山市的官方钓鱼码头是市中心的7号码头。每天早上，码头尽头的长椅上都坐满了从唐人街下山的老亚洲人，他们在码头上待一整天，做着我所见过最令人叹为观止、最有艺术感的钓鱼。全神贯注，一言不发，他们在三四根鱼竿之间来回穿梭，慢慢地把桶填满。
The stocks are trading a couple blocks away in the financial district, cars and crowds of tourists race by on the Embarcadero. But at the end of the pier, all is quiet. It's almost as if the fishermen themselves create silence. The fishermen seem so out of place in today's downtown San Francisco, that it's almost like they've been patiently fishing on the spot for centuries, while the city's great buildings rose and fell around them like the tides.
几个街区外的金融区股票正在交易，汽车和游客群在海滨大道上飞驰而过。但在码头尽头，一切都很安静。几乎就像渔夫们自己创造了寂静一样。渔夫在今天的旧金山市中心显得格格不入，几乎就像他们已经在那里耐心钓了几百年的鱼，而这座城市伟大的建筑却像潮水一样围绕着他们起落。
I watched one guy who hadn't made a catch all day. Almost imperceptibly, he started working it. His face was as calm and distant as a large ship on the horizon. Suddenly, he stood up with a flourish and reeled it in, a small two-foot shark. It went into the empty bucket.
我看着一个整天没钓到鱼的家伙。几乎无法察觉地，他开始操作起来。他的脸像地平线上的一艘大船一样平静而遥远。突然，他潇洒地站起来，收回鱼线，是一条两英尺长的小鲨鱼。它进了空桶。
In the buildings all around us, this decade's fabled economic boom is written in concrete and glass. But the fisherman's near empty bucket suggested that there are some who will remember this time differently.
在我们周围的建筑里，这十年传奇的经济繁荣是用混凝土和玻璃书写的。但渔夫近乎空荡的桶表明，有些人会以不同的方式记住这个时代。
As he leaned his arm back for another cast of the line, the Transamerica Pyramid stood directly behind him, confident of its own indestructibility. Seeming to say, the big one will never come. These buildings will always grow taller. The fisherman's bucket will always be empty. But as the late afternoon fog surrounded us and the line hit the water, you couldn't help but think to yourself that anything could happen.
当他向后挥动手臂再次抛线时，泛美金字塔大厦就矗立在他身后，对自己不可摧毁性充满信心。似乎在说，大鱼永远不会来。这些建筑会永远长得更高。渔夫的桶会永远空着。但随着午后的雾气包围了我们，鱼线击中水面，你禁不住想，任何事情都可能发生。
Iggy Scam writes a zine called Scam .
伊吉·斯卡姆写了一本名叫《骗局》的杂志。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Starlee Kine. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann. Musical help from Marika Partridge and [? Terry Hecker. ?] Marketing by [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and the friendly folks at PRI. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼和斯塔利·凯恩参与。贡献编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗赫林、亚历克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼提供制作帮助。玛丽卡·帕特里奇和[？特里·赫克？]提供音乐帮助。营销由[听不清]和国际公共广播电台的友好伙伴提供。伊丽莎白·迈斯特运营我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thislife.org.
如果你想购买这期节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who reminds you--
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚提醒你——
White Sox and Bubbles are coming back to y'all. And I'm not playing.
白袜和泡泡会回来缠着你们的。我不是在玩。
I'm not playing either. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我也不是在玩。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。